Speaker 1: So on the bonus show today, we are
going to talk about Steve Bannon's conviction
on two counts of contempt of Congress. But what
I want to talk about here is that even after this
conviction and you got to say he is certainly
acting with conviction, he went back on his
program and started talking about shock troops,
deconstructing the government brick by brick,
more coded language that sounds very much
like an insurrectionist coup. Steve Bannon
calls on 4000 shock troops to deconstruct the
government brick by brick. He's back with more
incendiary rhetoric against the nation days
after his contempt of Congress conviction.
Check out this clip and understand that he's
calling for treason again. And there are people
who listen to this guy and who act based on what
he says. And these are not accidental phrases that
he's using. This is all very specifically targeted
to have a particular impact on the people that
hear it. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: We're talking about
a republic and democracy because
essentially we have taken on the model
of really Davos in the Chinese Communist Party
of an authoritarian state, undemocratic with
institutions that are not democratic.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that we're
going to listen to the entire thing. But this is
one of those, oh, the Democrats are going to do
voter fraud. And really, they tried
to steal an election. They didn't win.
One of the principles of traditional conservatism
is small government. Now we know that in many ways
they never really adhered to it. They're like
small government. But let's decide who can get
married. Small government, but let's decide what
medical procedures women can have. Okay. We know
that it was B.S. all along, but while continuing
to claim that they are against authoritarianism,
they are increasingly using government
as a way to achieve what they want,
rather than allowing markets or public opinion
or culture, whatever to make decisions they want
whenever they see something they don't like. They
want courts up to and including the Supreme Court
to just make decisions that favor them. We saw
this when it came to the 2020 election. Didn't
win on election. Well, just start filing lawsuits
and get courts and judges and the Supreme Court,
if you're lucky enough to decide that you actually
get to be president anyway. When it comes to
abortion. Ban. Ban. Pass a ban.
Get the Supreme Court to overturn.
Ban it at the state level. Ban it at
the federal level. Ban contraception
or access to it or standard access to it
without a co-pay as part of health insurance.
They increasingly are the ones trying to use
state power to achieve their goals. But Bannon
insists that it's the left that wants to do that.
Speaker 5: And state capitalism. Now, how do you
combat that? You combat that by deconstructing.
You have to take it apart brick by brick.
You know, Steve, it gets my deplorable blood going
on a monday morning to hear Jonathan Swan talk
about a purge, a purge of the administrative
state. Now, of course, he means that to be an
exposé and to be a hit on our movement. We could
do exactly the opposite and wear it as a badge
of honor. And it tells me that, yes, Jonathan
Swan recognizes that there is a plan in place
that this second Trump term is going to be far
more consequential than the first one. And the
first one was quite consequential. Come on, get
Mike. And we're going to have a one hour special
on the job. That's one Axios articles.
I want everybody to understand deeply
exactly what we're doing here, exactly what's
going on, because you're gonna be part of it.
And particularly when people come and step in
and say, Hey, I want to be one of those 4000
shock troops, or there's going to be lots of other
opportunities, lots of other opportunities, lots.
Speaker 1: Of opportunities for treason to be a
shock. Troop. And what exactly shock troops do, of
course, is nebulous, and he's calling for treason
again. And the point here of using the various
euphemisms is for plausible deniability. Right.
Deconstruct the administrative state. Okay. Well,
that's just basically taking apart centers of
power in government by eliminating departments.
And that doesn't sound violent, does it?
Well, though, it's not in and of itself,
but it's all part of this idea that they need
shocking action. And when you talk about troops,
of course, you're alluding to force and military
force and weapons and all of these different
things. This was a term coined by Steve. Steve
Bannon. This is all meant to keep them all ginned
up and at the ready to do whatever it is that
you need them to do. And by them I'm talking, of
course, about the supporters, the patsies who end
up the prosecuted. Right, who end up prosecuted
after the January six riots while Donald Trump
flies around giving speeches. So one other clip
that I want to look at here. And he's using, we're
going to kill the administration in the crib.
That's another phrase that Bannon loves to use.
Speaker 5: And we said, we kill this in the crib.
Now we. We're just a small part of it. But
remember, we've been maniacally focused
since we talked. Friends were to kill
this administration in the crib. Hey,
I don't care. Bennie Thompson doesn't like
that. Nancy Pelosi doesn't like it or who
doesn't like it? Doesn't Obama. I don't
care if you don't like it. Suck on it.
We're destroying this illegitimate regime. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Sort of weird, by the way, that people
who claim to be pro-life, you talk about killing
things in the crib as if that's a good thing to
do. But let's put that aside for a moment. These
are extraordinarily dangerous and violent ideas.
That's one side to this. But I also don't want
to ignore the likely cynical reality that there's
a fundraising aspect to this thing. Somewhere
there there is almost certainly some motivation
in this new plan that Bannon starts to talk about
now, which which seems to be wrapped up with
what many are writing as an imminent announcement
of a 2024 candidacy by Donald Trump. There's
probably some fundraising element to it as well.
Notice also that at one previous point in time,
Steve Bannon promised 20,000 shock troops. Now
he's down to 4000. Maybe recruiting isn't going
particularly well, but this is what happens when
you don't properly punish a coup attempt and make
sure that everybody knows that even at the top
level, there's going to be consequences. Yes, the
patsies in the Capitol, they got arrested. They're
getting charged. Some of them are going to prison.
But if you don't punish the people at the top
level, it's going to continue and you will see
it stop when either the leaders are properly
punished or the coup succeeds. And that latter
option would be very, very bad. And of course,
the fear is with a63 Supreme Court in your favor,
that the success of the coup will take place
in 2024. Going into 2025, Bannon's dangerous
Bannon should be in prison, but even being in
prison, where he will likely spend some time or
jail, we'll find out about that. His sentencing
is in October. He still will likely be able to
wield influence. And one of the things judges are
supposed to do when they sentence individuals is
consider whether they're remorseful and consider
whether they're likely to break the law again.
Steve Bannon is not remorseful and Steve Bannon
is openly saying he is going to continue getting
involved in all sorts of horrible things.
He's itching to do more harm and he should
get the maximum sentence. He'll probably end up
with the minimum, which I believe is 30 days.